[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici les titres de ce vendredi à 9 mars
la boxe un sport qui se conjugue au
féminin la pratique s'ouvre de plus en
plus sophie depuis quelques années à
montigny le bretonneux une initiation
gratuite était organisée pour tenter de
convaincre les curieuses d'un soir parmi
elles notre journaliste mélanie poquet
qui n'a pas hésité à enfiler les gants
pour tester ce sport - de condamnation
mais plus d'applications emmanuel macron
a présenté cette semaine ses
orientations pour une meilleure
efficacité des peines les plus courtes
et tenter de réduire enfin la population
carcérale en france les mesures
annoncées sont elles les bonnes nous
poserons la question à mariama boursiers
doyen de la faculté de droit et de
sciences politiques à lui vécu dans le
reste de l'actualité retour sur
l'inauguration de la rd 30 à plaisir
après plusieurs années de travaux et une
consigne à vélo installé à la gare de
versailles rive gauche pour plus de
sécurité
longtemps réservé aux hommes la boxe
s'ouvre donc aux femmes depuis à les
années 90 ce sport olympique depuis 2012
la boxe féminine française a brillé
d'ailleurs lors des derniers jo à rio
avec deux médailles une d'or et une
d'argent
mais alors pourquoi les femmes
plébiscitent de plus en plus ce sport
miquel et demi d'euros et mélanie poké
ont participé à la soirée d'initiation
de l'académie self qui défend ses boxe
anglaise de montigny le bretonneux
reportage 56000 à l'essence y est
actuellement en 2014 la fédération
française de boxe collé d'une des plus
grosses progressions de féminisation
19% le football et le rugby c'est 5% -
alors pourquoi un tel succès réponse le
ring je pense que ça peut faire
renforcer le les muscles tout ça donc
prouver ce pourrait être ma nation je
pense que c'est un milieu plutôt
masculin et snecma attire aussi pourquoi
pas les 6 et là c'était spécial
problèmes de la femme donc
donc c'est tout ensemble c'est un sport
on pense pas spécialement à le faire
quand on est une fille nous penser dit
voilà on s'initie si ça nous plaît on
continue
[Musique]
alors avant de la faire la boxe mais pas
un sport d'hommes exactement c'est aussi
un sport de femmes et sont vraiment
toute leur place dans la discipline est
d'ailleurs on a aujourd'hui tout tout
type de pratiques qui permettent aux
femmes de s'adonner au noble art
mais c'est différent j'y mais je ne sais
pas tout à fait les mêmes mouvements de
tête ramène boxe c'est pas alors c'est
les mêmes techniques c'est les mêmes
règles mais c'est pas la même pratique
en fait les femmes vont chercher plus la
condition physique
le cardio le renforcement musculaire et
pour moins cher chez l'opposition et
sont plus frileuses en général et donc
avons cherché à s'amuser et à pratiquer
différentes
vous est il qu'à nous imagine c'est un
sport aussi qui entraîne une maîtrise de
son corps aussi une bonne connaissance
oui c'est un sport qui est très complet
en fait on utilise les membres
inférieurs pour les déplacements on a
besoin d'explosivité et on utilise les
membres supérieurs pour l'attaqué la
défense est donc là on a besoin
également de
la qualité physique et donc ça fait un
sport très très complète essayé bien sûr
un grand plaisir à léon dubois
allez on y va
[Musique]
à
un entraînement de boxe durent en
général deux heures il existe différents
styles à bout quand on peut dire bravo à
mélanie poké une quinzaine d'ateliers
organisés à l'occasion de la journée
internationale des droits de la femme
dans une concession automobile en
partenariat avec l'association créactive
le groupe courtois automobile a
transformé son showroom peugeot a de
montilliers le bretonneux en soirée
spéciale autour du bien-être maquillage
biologique huiles essentielles et art
thérapie un événement pour faire évoluer
aussi l'image sur l'automobile souvent
considéré comme un milieu masculin
réaction au micro de camille lambert
on a besoin de féminiser notre métier il
faut quand même savoir il ya des
statistiques qui sont assez effrayante
quand on aime et on les partage pas dans
le métier parce qu'on n'est pas
forcément fier c'est que 80% des femmes
qui vivent en concession à 6000 ça aller
chez le dentiste
donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire puisque
aujourd'hui un client sur deux est une
femme que les femmes sont au moins pour
moitié dans le choix du véhicule
familial s'est déjà montré à nos
clientes qu'on peut aussi passer une
journée moment sympathique dans une
concession ou de vulgairement dans un
garage mari et ma boursiers bonsoir vous
êtes le doyen de la faculté de droit et
de sciences politiques à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
avant de parler d actualité qui concerne
la justice un mot sur sûr c'est
peut-être ces journées des droits des
femmes soient les débats qui agitent
beaucoup la société en ce moment sur
l'égalité hommes femmes est ce que vous
diriez que c'est des débats qui touche
aussi le monde judiciaire que c'est un
monde assez discriminatoire ou où les
femmes ont du mal à se faire une place
écoutez non je ne pense pas pas plus que
ne peut l'être la société que je ne
qualifierais pas discriminatoire il ya
des problématiques spécifiques pour
atteindre une égalité réelle entre les
hommes et les femmes qui ne passent pas
à mon sens par une journée de la femme
dédiés comme comme ça a été le cas hier
voilà mais ça ne l'est pas
particulièrement dans le monde
judiciaire qui est plutôt féminisé mais
effectivement féminisée dans les
premiers grades et les fonctions les
premières fonctions notamment dans la
magistrature et puis ensuite on constate
que dans les fonctions les plus
importantes qu'il ya beaucoup moins de
femmes que donc il ya encore une
inégalité qui ont tendance à se résorber
je pense au fil des ans et aujourd'hui
le gouvernement cherche justement à
réduire ces problèmes d' inégalités
hommes femmes
est-ce que vous pensez que la solution
c'est plus de plus de
de pénal c'est des lois plus dure envers
les entreprises qui ne respecteraient
pas l'égalité hommes femmes au sein des
entreprises ou alors c'est plutôt sur
d'autres leviers qu'il faut agir peut
être l'éducation puisque vous êtes doyen
à la faculté
non je ne pense pas du tout sur le pénal
ça c'est certain la voiture grise
éventuellement qui semble que semble
vouloir sur la protection des femmes
oui sur les quotas dans les conseils
d'administration je pense que déjà
beaucoup pas été fait asim pas si
longtemps vingt ans plus tôt plutôt
réduit donc moi je suis très réservé sur
cette voie là parce que il ne faut pas
dévoyé non plus de ce qu'elle est ce
qu'elle est ce qu est la voie pénale qui
doit rester sur pour des faits il me
semble d'une importance peut être plus
grande que celle ci en tout cas c'est
pour moi pas le pas le bon moyen et
l'éducation l'éducation l'information
sont les premiers outils dont on dispose
et et à l'épaule et puis ensuite à la
faculté et d'exemples aussi sont
vraiment des éléments il semble plus
important on va revenir aux actualités /
sur la justice puisque le gouvernement
semble avoir fait le choix de durcir
l'application des lois tout en réduisant
leur nombre pour les peaux les plus
courtes
c'est le sens des annonces faites par le
président de la république en milieu de
semaine en déplacement à agen dans le
sud-ouest avant de rentrer dans le
détail de ces annonces globalement est
ce que vous estimez que ces réformes
annoncées en tout cas voulu par le
président et le gouvernement vont dans
le bon sens
- de moins de peine en tout cas pour les
plus courtes mais en tout cas plus
d'applications pour ces peines quand
elles sont prononcés oui alors dans
l'absolu les grands chantiers mis en
oeuvre mise en oeuvre par par la
ministre et par le président sont de
toute façon nécessaire c'est certain sur
le fonctionnement sur l'aide de la
justice sur le sens et l'efficacité de
la peine
exactement je crois que il y à une
évidence c'est que la question de la
bonne exécution et d'exécution tout
court pour certaines peines est
essentiel c'est à dire que ce qui marche
et on le sait criminologique mans c'est
que la peine soit exécutée et qu'elle
soit exécutée dans des délais brefs ce
qui n'est pas forcément le cas de ce que
les magistrats ne délivre pas forcément
de mon à dépôt à l'issue des audiences
et donc laisse partir librement
un prévenu qui a été condamné à une
peine d'emprisonnement qui ensuite doit
être sollicitée par les services
judiciaires
donc tout ça prend du temps et parfois
n'est pas exécutée du tout donc là il ya
un vrai problème d'efficacité qui ne
permet pas de donner son vrai sens à la
peine qui est une peine exécutée et
rapidement après la sentence le
président de la république dit aussi que
les peines les plus courtes ne servent à
rien et ce que vous êtes d'accord sur ce
point de vue là quand on parle des
peines les plus courtes on parle d des
peines de moins d'un mois voire moins de
six mois
oui car ça c'est un problème on a du mal
à comprendre quand on n'est pas issu du
milieu judiciaire en quoi ça ne sert à
rien est ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer ça peut-être oui c'est un type
d'accord c'est un problème récurrent je
crois la question la peine de moins d'un
an
au delà d'un an ou un au delà d'un an
c'est qu'on est dans d'édition des
délits quand même d'une gravité certaine
les peines de moins d'un an sont
prononcés beaucoup dans des contentieux
type contentieux routiers notamment avec
alcoolisation substances psychotropes
ingérés par par le conducteur dont ils
sont aussi des contentieux et crée
effectivement graves pour lesquels vous
avez des peines de 1 3 6 mois de prison
auquel on reproche à juste titre un côté
désocialisant qui est très important
vous partez trois mois en prison vous
perdez votre travail
regardez reims la mine qui qui est
vraiment très très lourd donc il est
certain que globalement je pense qu'il
est bien me trouver d'autres solutions
que ces peines courtes dans certains cas
sur décade récidivistes ça peut être un
électrochoc mais globalement je crois
que c'est une bonne idée alors en résumé
les annonces vont permettre désormais
plus de plus de peines prononcées en
dessous d'un mois les peines de un à six
mois seront tels exécutée hors de prison
sauf exception en revanche du coup pour
les peines supérieures à vingt ans il
n'y aura plus d'aménagements possibles
se pose du coup la question de la
surpopulation carcérale puisque c'est
aussi l'objectif de ces annonces d'un
côté on va baisser la population
carcérale mais en rendant un possible
aménagement des peines pour plus d'un an
on peut aussi réaugmenter cette
population carcérale est ce qu'il y aura
un effet balançoire est-ce qu'on va se
neutraliser ou alors il y aura quand
même moins de moins de monde dans les
prisons entre guillemets alors le terme
que vous reprenez aménagements je sais
pas ce que ce qu il recoupe la dent
l'annoncerai par le président 2 ans de
deux peines vous pouvez aménager les
peines oui c'est plus le cas désormais
ce sera plus le balancement entre les
plus plus de peine nous prononcer de
plus d'un an et celle de moins d'un an
font que numériquement ça fera sortir du
monde de prison et sur l'aménagement des
peines de moins d'un an type bracelet
électronique
ce sont des systèmes qui pour l'instant
n'ont pas fait tant leurs preuves que ça
parce qu'on sait que au bout de quelques
semaines ou quelques mois un porter de
bracelet électronique rompt ses
obligations et que c'est pas un système
en tout cas efficace pour l'instant le
bras son aile et on ne marche pas très
bien aujourd'hui le travail d'intérêt
général c'est aussi une piste qui est
lancée en tout cas relancer qui
souhaitent être activé par le
gouvernement est ce que ça c'est quelque
chose d'efficace de travailler pour la
société
moi ça me paraît vraiment quelque chose
de très très intéressant de toute façon
le travail est formateur est à un côté
je pense qu'ils portent vers vers l'âme
vers une réinsertion certaines donc ça
me paraît être une très bonne piste
toujours sur les prisons et pour
terminer sur ce sujet il ya une députée
ville noise très actif sur le sujet
c'est yale brawn pie v député de la 5e
circonscription des yvelines et
présidente aussi de la commission des
lois
ll est favorable à l'ouverture de deux
prisons ouvertes sont des prisons ou les
où les détenus peuvent se balader
peuvent travailler peuvent faire la
cuisine
alors ce n'est pas évidemment en sortie
totale mais on est dans un espace clos
est ce que est ce que vous pensez
aujourd'hui qu'en france le problème
c'est qu'on a aussi une vision trop trop
répressive peut-être de la prison des
détenus en général le regard de la
société est trop dur porté sur sur les
prisonniers et qu'on ne souhaite pas
forcément on ne fait pas tout pour
essayer de les réinsérer les considérer
comme des comme des citoyens aussi un
peu comme aux etats-unis est-ce que
c'est ça le problème aujourd'hui de la
france et je pense qu'on il ya des
modèles qui marchent manifestement aux
normes du nord notamment les modèles
civic et beaucoup qui existe beaucoup au
danemark exactement
nous sommes pas sur la même population
carcérale mais sur les mêmes moyens les
mêmes richesses naturelles
il disait tout à l'heure par exemple
pour les pour les chauffards a les trois
mois en prison ça peut être très dur où
des empires beaucoup de mon père a on
peut perdre sa famille on peut perdre
son travail
c est ce qu on n'a pas une vision trop
haut trop répressive du jeu je crois que
si nous étions pas dans des situations
de surpopulation de conditions d'hygiène
déplorables dans certains établissements
pénitentiaires la question se poserait
pas la même façon de ces répressif la
présence d'une privation de liberté
c'est le maximum de d'atteinte que l'on
peut porter à nos droits individuels
je crois qu'il faut plutôt ambitionner
de d'améliorer avec la construction
c'est 7000 places de prison avec des
moyens d'encadrement
il me semble que c'est peut-être plus
plus réaliste que des modèles certes
très vertueux mais qui pour l'instant
paraissent à s'éloigner ce que l'on est
capable de faire
en qualité de doyen de la faculté de
droit de l'ue est ce qu est ce que vous
diriez encore que les carrières
judiciaires ça ça donne envie aux jeunes
est ce que est ce qu'il ya toujours à un
tel intérêt on sait qu'historiquement on
souhaite beaucoup pas les endroits quand
on est en terminale s que c'est toujours
autant le cas aujourd'hui
oui je crois nos amphis sont pleins et
puis ce sont des métiers le droit comme
la science politique qui mène à un panel
justement de choix de carrière très
important et qui sont très intéressante
au fond parce qu'elle touche aussi au
fonctionnement de notre société
un mot encore puisque ce week end ce
sont les journées portes ouvertes
c'est le 10 mars les journées portes
ouvertes du tout un peu en quoi c'est
essentiel pour les pour les élèves de
terminale
il s'agit vraiment de rencontrer le
corps professoral les équipes
administratives de la faculté de droit
de sciences de l'institut supérieur de
management de l'ubs est ce qu notamment
et donc de s'approprier un peu ce que
serait leur futur parcours s'il décide
de s'inscrire sur parcours super de
choisir le droit où la science politique
par exemple
donc ce sont vraiment des temps des
changes qu'il me semble sont très
importants pour les futurs bacheliers
dans l'oeuf briller sens fait de marie
leur parcours c'est demain après midi de
14h à 17h30 sur les différents sites de
l'île est ce qu est d'ailleurs puisque
vous parliez de parcours sub peut-être
pour les lycéens qui nous regardent ils
ont jusqu'au 13 mars pour remplir leurs
voeux
sur la plateforme merci marie emma
boursiers d'être venu sur le plateau
vous êtes je le rappelle le doyen de la
faculté de droit et de sciences
politiques de l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines merci à vous
et bon week-end merci nicolas on passe
désormais à l'actualité de la semaine
cette semaine marquée par les nombreuses
animations organisées par les villes de
l'agglomération pour la journée des
droits des femmes
on vous en parlait à guyancourt c'est
tout le mois de mars que la commune est
mobilisée avec une série d'événements
spéciaux pour la 8e édition du temps des
femmes ateliers expositions pièces de
théâtre conférences les précisions de
bénédicte alliés cohen adjoint au maire
elle était sur notre plateau lundi soir
le droit des femmes ce n'est pas une
question de d'une journée et pour nous
c'est important de mettre en lumière
pendant un bon mois mais c'est un
travail quotidien de tous les services
et ce temps des femmes à guyancourt et
surtout une transversalité de tous les
services en direction des habitants ça
c'est important de préciser parce que
nombreux ateliers sont en direction des
habitants et puis la diversité donc
voilà bien sûr c'est une vraie
préoccupation quotidienne et pour en
revenir sur notre temps des femmes
cette année
peut-être en rapport avec le sport notre
thématique et tout aurait mouvement
s'est encore les mouvements femmes corps
mes mouvements
en effet c'était important de
de décliner autour du corps de la santé
bien sûr du sport bien sûr mais aussi
réappropriation de son propre corps
c'est un dossier sur la table depuis
plus de 20 ans la nouvelle ère des 30 au
niveau de plaisir a été inaugurée mardi
matin en présence notamment de valérie
pécresse la présidente de la région ile
de france
axe souvent saturée entre elancourt et
plaisir la route départementale a été
doublée et réaménagé trois ans de
travaux ont été nécessaires un chantier
chiffré à 87,5 millions d'euros dont 54
à la charge du département des yvelines
sujet de patrick jacques de dixmude
quentin le frère et wilfrid riche et 30
mille véhicules par jour empruntent cet
axe de la route départementale 30 à
hauteur de plaisir autant
d'automobilistes qui devrait donc être
soulagés et passer moins de temps dans
les bouchons
après trois ans de travaux la deux fois
deux voies est ouverte le dossier a tout
de même été lancée voici vingt ans c'est
une des caractéristiques je crois
aujourd'hui de la france
la multiplication des recours la
multiplication des d enquête d
différentes phases administratives qui
sont inimaginables font que bien entendu
on a rallongé les délais de réalisation
il faudrait j'espère que ce message va
être entendu c'est qu'il y ait moins de
recours quand on fait des
infrastructures ont fait pas pour
embêter les gens ont fait pour améliorer
la vie des gens
la patience aura payé le doublement de
la route sa compagne de murs acoustiques
sur plus de 2 km es22 souterrain c'est
la base même d'une femme qui est les
fondamentaux pour que notre ville puisse
avoir des aspirations encore
supplémentaires dans un développement à
la fois commercial économique et un
cadre de vie parce que ça apporte
effectivement à grand confort à notre
ville
on aura besoin au brouillage ailleurs on
en a déjà beaucoup moins 87 millions
d'euros ont été investis 54 par la
région 33 par le département et les
travaux se poursuivent avec notamment à
l'automne une passerelle pour que
cyclistes et piétons puissent franchir
la nationale 12 transport toujours avec
la consigne à vélo qui est en service à
la gare de versailles château rive
gauche depuis le 19 février dernier elle
permet à chacun de laisser en toute
sécurité son vélo avant de prendre le
train l'inauguration officielle s'est
déroulée mardi matin en présence des
élus locaux
wilfrid riche et 128 places de
stationnement réservées exclusivement
aux vélos en gare de versailles château
rive gauche les usagers adeptes du deux
roues peuvent dorénavant prendre
sereinement leur train grâce à vail
ebooks
c'est sur ces prestations d'ae ligocki
va
améliorer la régularité des trains mais
néanmoins il ya beaucoup de gens qui
nous disent ok on comprend vous avez des
problèmes sur les trains mais au moins
excuse moi je peut garer mon vélo à la
gare de façon sécurisée et donc c'est
très important aussi de s'occuper de ce
premier de ce dernier kilomètre 5800
places de stationnement ont déjà été
créés à travers l'île de france vingt
mille seront disponibles d'ici 2020
région et sncf se partagent le
financement de 120 mille euros ont été
nécessaires pour cet espace dans la cité
royale ile-de-france mobilité avec un s
c'est le nouveau nom du syndicat des
transports d'île de france s'occupe dieu
des franciliens du départ de leur
domicile jusqu'à leur arrivée au bureau
c'est à dire qu'on essaye de travailler
sur tous les petits points noirs pour
améliorer la qualité de service aux
voyageurs améliorer la qualité de
service et aussi mettre des espaces de
coworking dans la gare quand on attend
son train c'est pouvoir mettre des
recharges de portable c'est pouvoir
offrir des nouveaux services pour les
usagers le fonctionnement de ce service
est simple l'accès possible 7 jours sur
7 de 5h à 1h30 avec une carte navigo en
cours de validité et moyennant un
abonnement annuel de 20 euros
atout supplémentaire de ce nouvel espace
la présence de seize casiers individuels
pour recharger les vélos électriques à
versailles toujours mercredi le réseau
accueille des migrants en yvelines s'est
rassemblée devant la préfecture une
cinquantaine de personnes s'est réunie
pour demander un meilleur accueil des
migrants en france et dans le
département des yvelines
pour eux il est largement possible de
faire mieux et plus écoutez cette ces
réactions recueillies par quentin le
frère donc on a un rôle de vigilance
aussi de vie et de dallaire de la
population sur la france pays terre
d'accueil cinquième puissance du monde
peut accueillir dignement des migrants
pas quelques milliers mais bien 150 ou
200 mille personnes sur 66 millions ça
peut absolument aucun problème
d'autant plus que ces gens ces jeunes
ses fans je les entends nous apporte la
richesse de leur culture de
reconnaissance à saint quentin en
yvelines les élus se sont réunis en
conseil communautaire mardi pour
discuter du robe
rapport d'orientation budgétaire un
document et y fixer les grandes lignes
pour 2018 une année et un budget à qui
s'annonce contraint les détails avec
aurélie rose dans quelques semaines
saint-quentin-en-yvelines devra voter le
budget 2010 8 mai avant la présentation
du rapport d'orientation budgétaire est
une étape obligatoire
il permet aux élus de prendre
connaissance des contraintes financières
de l'agglomération première révélation
une baisse de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement de 35 millions d'euros
depuis 2014
si on projette jusqu'à 2020 ce sera 50
millions et si on va jusqu'à les
projections de 2023 on peut aller
jusqu'à près de 100 millions donc quelle
est la structure plus public ou
intercommunal chi qui peut résister à ça
c'est quand même c'est en rendant une
face comme très difficile pour cette
année 2010 8 il manque 13 millions
d'euros pour boucler le budget parmi les
pistes évoquées une mutation
institutionnelle
la réorganisation des services ou encore
une révision de la politique fiscale
moi je m'interdis rien mais c'est pas ce
serait pas ce serait pas un bon choix on
n'a jamais augmenté les impôts depuis
que nous sommes à la tête de 2,7 interco
franchement c'est pas c'est pas un choix
c'est plutôt nous le dv connaît le
développement économique faire des
économies aussi restreinte peut-être des
investissements bien sûr un peu plus
serré tous les budgets
c'est plus se dire que cela qu'on se
dirige on va regarder avec beaucoup
d'attention la question des services à
la population en un haut niveau de
service dans cette agglomération et on
tient ce que ça soit maintenue et que
d'autres projets d'autres sujets plus en
plus annexes ne soit pas privilégiée
donc en revenir aux fondamentaux de ce à
quoi doit servir l'agglomération c'est à
dire rendre des services aux habitants
de 50 ans
prochaine étape pour les douze communes
qui composent saint quentin en yvelines
se réunir autour de la table pour faire
des choix
trois rendez vous sont programmés avant
le vote du budget en avril à saint
quentin en yvelines le printemps des
poètes a débuté le lancement de ce
rendez vous annuel a eu lieu en plein
coeur du marché de maurepas il ya
quelques jours
la 20e édition est placée sous le signe
des ardeurs aurélie rond et nicolas
landry des poèmes déclamés entre les
fruits et les fleurs une scène quelque
peu insolite pour lancer le printemps
des poètes thème retenu cette année
ardeurs au pluriel
un thème que la poétesse québécoise
nicole brossard connaît bien
allons du côté des sanglots langer et
notre ardeur dans la question est la
cerise
les ardeurs sait il en faut toujours
surtout lorsqu'on est en poésie c'est la
motivation c'est la passion c'est la
fulgurance je sais que des brèdes
écrivent dans le grand calme dans
l'anxiété moi je pense que j'écris plus
tôt je suis plutôt du côté de l'ardeur
tout naturellement c'est donc sous le
signe de toutes les ardeurs que se
déroulera cette 20e édition
coordonné par les itinéraires poétique
le lieu choisi pour le lancement de la
manifestation n'était pas anodin le
thème ardeurs est un thème très général
on va dire très générique c'est à dire
qu'on peut y mettre ce qu'on veut de
dans un vote pourrait parler de l'ardeur
l'ardeur au travail ces gens qui sont là
pendant des journées entières sur des
marchés ils ont intérêt à avoir une
sacrée ardeurs intérieure et une envie
de voilà deux de faire quelque chose de
leur vie pour venir sur ce marché une
quinzaine de comédiens est intervenu sur
l'ensemble du marché pour dire des
textes et distribuer des cartes postales
sur lesquels avaient été imprimées des
poèmes
je trouve que de faire sortir la poésie
en vie pour tout le monde c'est super
voilà qui ont d'abord profité et
découvrir un petit peu que la poésie
c'est toute la vie et tous les jours et
a toujours un problème
il ya des choses à redire et le
printemps des poètes c'est jusqu'au 18
mars sur saint quentin en yvelines
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo retour
de l'actualité en direct lundi à 18h sur
l'antenne de tva soit 118 bon week-end à
tous et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]